on a un modèle éducatif qui s'est
développé à partir des années 70
probablement pour d'excellentes raisons
de disons de favoriser la liberté
individuelle l'écoute envers les besoins
des enfants mais qui a des effets
pervers et dans parmi ces effets pervers
que nous subissons aujourd'hui parce que
une génération voire deux générations
après on se retrouve avec une forme de
de de de rapport à la loi qui s'est
répandu et qui me semble très
problématique puisque cette politique de
l'enfantroi aboutit à développer une
mentalité disons de toute puissance du
Briss de refus de toute contrainte de
considérer que toute forme de contrainte
sur la liberté individuelle est
forcément négative et forcément
insupportable de focalisation sur les
droits au détriment des devoirs de
fétichisation de la liberté individuelle
au détriment de l'intérêt général ce qui
me semble être un effet pervers de la
libération des meœurs depuis de
génération libéralisation que nous
pouvions euh euh approuver mais dont
nous voyons aujourd'hui des effets
pervers et c'est ce que j'ai proposé de
nommer euh en m'appuyant sur un
sociologue qui m cher Norbert Elias le
processus de décivilisation alors
qu'est-ce que Norbert Elias entendait
par ce terme il entendait un processus
qui défait progressivement ce qu'il
avait longuement étudié dans ses travaux
à travers le à savoir le processus de
civilisation des meurs c'est-à-dire de
progressive acquisition d'une d'un
autocontrôle d'une autocontraintte sur
ses propres pulsions qui fait partie du
de donc de ce que elas appelait le
processus de civilisation du monde
occidental qui aboutit à toutes sortes
de de de conséquences que je ne vais pas
préciser parce que ce serait trop long
mais qui qui qui qui définit aujourd'hui
les fondements du cadre de la civilité
hein sur le le fait de contrôler ses
émotions de contrôler ses tendances à la
violence et cetera bon or Elias lui-même
à noter que ce processus n'est pas
irréversible et que il peut se retourner
par moment dans des moments de
régression où c'est non plus la
civilisation mais la décivilisation qui
intervient et cette
décivilisation elle se manifeste
notamment par cette ce desserrement de
l'autocontrôle et cette possibilité de
euh de de passer à l'acte de façon
violente de façon pulsionnelle et je
pense que ces émeutes en ont donné un
exemple tout à fait tout à fait évident
alors Jérôme pour Fourquet a repris dans
son dernier livre cette notion du
processus de décivilisation elle a été
repris il a été repris également vous le
savez par Emmanuel Macron ça a été très
contesté par certains sociologues